have you ever met a guy named have you
ever heard of stephen kinser
yeah he wrote the sending godly book
right right yeah i talked to him about
that and his
his the way he explains mk ultra is just
fascinating how it's
basically you know he had to go to
different countries went to germany
just because he was violating the human
right like the stuff he was doing he had
a license to kill from the government
like he was destroying people so you had
him on the podcast yeah
how'd it go it was great maybe it was
you guys somebody asked me if i would go
on a podcast with him
and i said yes it was yeah i wanted to
have you guys both on together and i
said you know
i said i don't think he'd do it i my
book
his book is very straightforward you
know he's a new york times best-selling
author
yeah not academic but it's very sober
you know and i don't think he'd want to
be in my category
uh yeah he kind of shut down a little
bit when i started to ask him about
charles manson
yeah of course yeah i'd love to sit down
and ask him
why louis jolly west isn't even in his
index in his book
and this guy my book was already out
before his book
and nobody wants to take somebody else's
findings even you would obviously
acknowledge them
but i have the documents i show that he
was gottlieb's first
psychiatric partner when he was at the
lackland air force base in texas i have
all the letters
that i found that west accidentally left
in his archive at ucla
where they're page after page after page
describing what kind of experiments
they're going to do they're all illegal
on human on patients and wes says we can
hide it from the other doctors
uh on these wards because the patients
are already suffering from mental
illness
so what i do to them is just going to
look like another one of their
but it's going to be with my drugs and
hypnosis and gottlieb's like well you
have to double
you know all the ways they're going to
hide their correspondence scott lee had
an
alias he wanted wes to have an alias but
west didn't want one because he thought
that would draw attention if anybody
caught that so he did that for from 53
to at least 67.68 i've got a paper
record of him
corresponding with gottlieb and nobody
had has the unredacted record like i do
like everything got uh
kinser saw here's a little bit of my
sour grapes yeah with stuff he got
through other people's freedom of
information act requests
and it's all redacted because i read
this book he doesn't have new
information in there from documents he's
got
he's got a lot of great stuff in there
that fills in got gaps
but for him to completely ignore the
scientists that
john marks john marx is the
whistleblower
who was a state department official who
found these financial records for
mkultra
went to congress told them about it
caused the congressional investigation
seymour hersh the famous investigative
journalist worked with marx and he wrote
the first big
stories in 1974 or five on this
horrifying program that our government
did
since the early 50s where they were
testing drugs
on people without their awareness using
making them human guinea pigs and some
of these people died
you know committed suicide or or had
massive nervous breakdowns right so i
was a
i didn't think kinser was if he hadn't
even mentioned
my findings i knew that he didn't want
to have anything to do with my book
why why would he what would be his
reasoning of of ignoring the stuff about
west um do you want to know what other
people tell me
yeah i do yeah i don't i i'm fascinated
by it do you know what a limited hangout
is
what's a limited hey a limited hangout
is when an agency
uses a media person to
release more information than they've
released before because it's coming out
anyway or is about to come out
to try to keep
people from suspecting even worse
so people accuse him of being i actually
would love to have him see this podcast
and
reach out to me and tell me he's going
to sue me or something so people i know
who are serious researchers think he's
paid by the cia it's like it's called a
limited hangout guy
wow so because people would question it
if it came directly to a government
agency there's not a lot of new
information in this book so there's only
been a couple really good books about mk
although they were all written in the
70s
john marks who was a whistleblower wrote
the very first book it's called
the search for the manchurian candidate
seymour hirsch wrote about it in a
couple books a guy named
optin and lyfton i think their names are
they wrote a book called the mind
manipulators in the late 70s
and nobody really wrote a book just
about mk ultra
until kinser did and i think his book
came out
like six months after mine or something
um
i think that i mean there's a lot of
stuff that's not substantiated in this
unless you read a cover to cover
it sounds crazy you know right and
that's why i mean i don't want it i know
that
i was on rogan and rogan's audience is
an audible you know they listen to books
and i'm so glad that people are buying
the book much more since i've been on
this show but almost all of them by the
audiobooks and i listen to audiobooks
now but if you do the audio
you're not seeing all the sourcing hold
it up hold it up a little higher so we
can see it on the uh yeah i think it's
60 70 pages of endnotes
and i don't know if you're an author but
what authors do in the endnotes is we
cheat
by adding more information than you
really should
because it doesn't fit in here you don't
want to stop the reader with like
where this came from right it disrupts
the flow yeah it disrupts the flow so
you put in the endnotes but then what
you do is you give a little more
that you had to cut out of the main
narrative because it gets too detailed
so some of my endnotes are like a half a
page long
and there's just so much information in
the endnotes i'm more proud of the
endnotes half the time really yeah
yeah so um yeah so people that get the
they also you don't get the pictures
right in the audio book no you don't get
the pictures yeah we got all these
it's just people i mean i don't know if
nobody has the
with all the you know media on on your
phone and everything these days
people don't have time to do anything i
can't blame them i'm the same way okay
you know who has time to sit down and
in front of a book for hours on end so
this is rudy in the guest house
having a party and that's candice bergen
uh and this is like 1966.
rudy altabelly and then this is him when
i would go see him in his apartment i
took that picture
of him and he had like 20 cats
wow yeah
that's incredible yeah so
what um yeah yeah you hold it up by your
face
um there you go and point yeah you can
just point to it that way the camera can
see it right this is rudy with his
kitten
yep yeah he took care of like 20
straight cats and had three crippled
dogs
and got mugged in his neighborhood like
once a month
and then when rudy lived in the guest
house in the 60s
whoever was in the main house became
especially the women would be like his
pet
so candace berger and he were very close
she was terry melcher's girlfriend so
that's a party he's having with karen
and our terrence
or candace in the guest house that's ca
that's candace and terry melcher
but yeah if you guys didn't get the if
you only get the audiobook
no i'm going to order i'm going to order
the hard the hardcover that's a picture
of me when i was young when i started
the damn thing and didn't
go white until my threats
wow man look at your computer oh yeah
the computer really tells it all i know
and the one at the bottom is me more
recently in my office with uh okay
oh my god what a bookshelf that is
that's incredible